[Musique]
nous faisons un numéro sur les
gens d'inspiration
Oh mr.  Rogers bonjour voisin la
maison de télévision pour enfants bien-aimée c'est si bon
de vous revoir aujourd'hui 400 mots oh gentil
mr.  Rogers, c'est tellement agréable de vous rencontrer,
cette pièce sera pour un numéro sur les
héros, vous considérez-vous comme un héros,
pas du tout d'
accord pour profiler mr.  Rogers à peu près la
personne la plus gentille que j'aie jamais rencontrée
dans notre émission J'ai essayé de regarder dans les
yeux d'un seul enfant Je ne sais tout simplement pas
s'il est un vrai garçon s'il vous plaît o mon enfant tous
ces gens font la queue pour vous dire leurs
problèmes  ce serait un
fardeau incroyable pour vous parfois nous devons demander
de l'aide et ce n'est pas grave
vous aimez les gens brisés comme moi je ne
pense pas que vous étiez brisé
[Musique]
nous devons faire savoir aux gens que chacun
d'eux est précieux
[Musique  ]
vous